all right let's go to our caller from
the 905 area code who's calling today
from nine one five hey David it's Justin
thankful from Monroe Washington how you
doing today uh oh not too bad
I was wondering putting aside all value
judgments and stuff like that yeah yeah
Republicans take on the shootings the
recent shootings have been to of course
blame video games and their younger
voter bloc especially those that
populate like the Donald subreddit and
4chan and stuff there's one thing they
love more than Donald Trump it's video
games I'm wondering how that plays from
like a political move to try to a lien
eight those people I'm not sure I
understand your question I want to make
sure I answer it correctly you're saying
that the same people that loved Trump
and are in these online alt-right
enclaves also love video games is that
right that's what you're asserting yes a
lot of them really do okay and then
you're saying that they are being
alienated by the discussions of what of
video games being to blame for the
shootings yeah oh uh listen I don't know
that all online alt writers love video
games I just don't know if that's the
case I'd have to you know maybe that's
true I'm not sure I think that it's
wrong to blame video games for the
violence so I think that that is also a
problem but I don't know that I'm sort
of like lined up with the way you're
framing the question such that I can
really answer it
well they a lot of white nationalist
radicalization comes from the idea that
young white men don't have any sort of a
banner to rally around you know women do
or other minorities and a lot of them
took up the game of or the tag of gamer
as their you know oppressed
quote-unquote group one cause the
gamergate thing and all of that I see a
lot of all right your game players this
group under gamergate which if you don't
know about gamer
I wish I was like you I wish I didn't
know about it either but years ago there
was this thing called DNA and so you're
saying that gamergate became a rallying
cry for a group whose identity would not
normally see them as the victims of
anything in society they were able to
say we are now the victims we are the
oppressed we are being targeted and that
gave an identity of a sort which was
then radicalized into the alt-right am i
sort of understanding yes sir and that's
a lot of the people that populate these
internet forums that are you know mostly
young white men interesting well listen
it this isn't the first I've heard of it
but you're presenting it in a very kind
of like cut and dry causal way I don't
know for sure how much there is to that
I'm not discounting it but it's
certainly something I want to look into
more all right okay very good Justin
country taking my call yes of course my
pleasure great great to hear from you